so we're here with the htc mytouch which
is the second iteration of the Google
phone and we actually have the first
iteration of the Google phone right here
this is the the g1 yeah so it's
basically ebony and ivory or just
Michael Jackson early Michael Jackson
Thriller yeah and this is the world
history the g1 did this it had a QWERTY
keypad on it it's pretty thick they've
refined the touchscreen enough that
they've gone completely they've done
away with all your keyboard there's no
more keyboard on it it's all touchscreen
still has the the trackball and the call
and back and home buttons on the front
and the point two megapixel camera
pretty much you're looking at very
similar phone with a few major
refinements I mean way more refinements
than Apple did from its first iteration
to the second one right yeah this is a
this is a much bigger this is a much
larger upgrade yeah
one of the biggest upgrades though was
something you can't actually see the
battery much much larger battery 77
hours of top time for and for a smart
phone that's fantastic that is fantastic
try getting that on your iPhone I know
the last time you and I went out we're
talking long distance it was like what
six hours and the phone just like
crapped out it's like we were right in
the throes of like a really good
conversation oh man I cried so hard
after that huh I know I was really upset
I had to go to the Telegraph you
afterwards yeah we did carrier pigeons
too so now that Apple has sort of closed
off and they've been denying certain
applications by Google boys like Google
Voice you shall not pass the line must
be drawn here that was that actually
made me like legitimately angry like a
lot of people are boycotting the iPhone
and boycotting Apple and up in arms
Jessica early because of that because
there's more freedom there there is more
freedom there but you know a lot of
people have said that part of the issue
is that it doesn't really have much to
do with Apple it has more to do with
AT&T wanting to sort of keep Google at
bay because frankly Google Voice really
is I mean it's an it's a telephone
industry killer exactly it has a
potential to cost ATT a lot of money and
they're really not into that they're
into reaping profits Stephen you have an
iPhone
I do have an iPhone so the lack of
Google Voice on the iPhone is that
enough for you to switch over to this
phone right here
probably not Danny I think it's a better
piece of hardware all in all I mean I
think having a headphone jack I think
the screen is larger so it's better for
multimedia so size does matter as good
as this touchscreen is I feel like you
can get a little bit more tender with
the iPhone